if you took the internet away from any
company any home the people the company
the processes the growth of Venetian
would stagnate really about half the
world has almost no ability to connect
to anything our mission is to enable
affordable Internet access for everyone
if you look back 10 years there was no
recognition of the need for
communications it was about malaria
tents and water and and and health
services which are all super super
important but foundational underneath
them these communications it's really
hard to get coverage into rural areas I
went to Africa and started to connect
schools and started to actually connect
them to the Internet and it was hard and
literally running fibre in the ground
would leak lynching the fiber and me
deep in the mud in looking at this
problem the only way to solve it was to
zoom out and look at it at a global view
when you load a web page over geo
satellite your internet access is very
slow it takes 20 seconds maybe oh three
B stands for the other 3 billion this is
the earth Oh three B satellites are
about right here
a Geo satellite is somewhere out here
it's a very large difference our
satellites solution is to provide a
system of satellites that circles the
earth and they are logically interlocked
with each other and they create a
coverage footprint on the ground that
very slowly moves over the earth they
talk to that satellite the next
satellite comes in just hands over to
the next satellite and right now ubi has
12 satellites and they provide very high
speed internet access directly to
telecoms around the world
looking at what every being is
accomplished we really decided that we
could go one step further
this is not a prop we do work here but
we're very small we're a start-up we
build the satellites the ability system
we build every component and every piece
of the system and then we model it our
satellites are about right there so when
you send a signal from the ground it
goes up to our satellite and back down
really fast the latency the time to go
from the ground of the satellite takes
longer this is 130 milliseconds the
latency then to get to the Geo satellite
is 800 milliseconds to go up and back we
bring it down into less than 30
milliseconds now your internet is
snapping but you need more satellites to
provide coverage this will be the
largest individual system of satellites
that's been launched what we've done
here is designed a system to be able to
bring services directly to end-users we
wanted individuals to be able to solve
their own problem locally this is a user
terminal this is an example you place
this user terminal on a school this
talks to satellite in the sky and then
it emits Wi-Fi and 3G out to the
surrounding area so that access is
available for everybody we're looking to
make it very affordable well I'd like to
see if you wanted all a price point on
it the entire system will likely cost
between 1.5 and 2 billion dollars
I am and we are sitting on a wave of
passion excitement and understanding
that we can accomplish this goal and
mission and that everyone around the
world can have equal access to the
world's information